[Music]
success in poultry farming is not just
about feeding chickens it's about
strategy discipline and
preparation many farmers struggle not
due to lack of resources but due to poor
planning and reactive
decisionmaking a strong foundation and
the right mindset set apart thriving
Farms from failing ones challenging will
come diseases fluctuating prices
unpredictable weather but instead of
blaming bad luck the wise farmer takes
control as epic tetus said it's not what
happens to you but how you react to it
that
matters in farming knowledge and
preparation are your greatest tools in
the following lessons you will learn how
to optimize feeding prevent disease and
manage your farm with
confidence before we begin take a moment
to assess your
farm identify one key
challenge keep it in mind as we go
through each lesson and take action
master your farm and success will
follow lesson one the foundation of
success chicken Coupe and living
environment a strong Foundation
determines success whether in farming or
life a well structured Coupe is not just
a shelter it's the difference between a
thriving flock and endless struggles
with disease and low
productivity if your chicken Coupe is
damp exposed to strong winds or
overcrowded what will happen your
chickens will become stressed their
immune systems will weaken and their
productivity will drop
this is not a matter of luck it's a
direct result of how well you prepare
their
environment many farmers make the
mistake of focusing on feeding medicine
while neglecting the coupe yet the coupe
is the first line of defense against
disease and poor growth a poorly
designed Coupe leads to overcrowding
stress and disease
outbreaks in contrast a well-planned
environment ensures Healthy Growth gr
better egg production and fewer
losses focus on three main factors
ventilation prevents respiratory
diseases and keeps the air fresh Space
Management avoids pecking issues and
stress from
overcrowding hygiene reduces the risk of
infections by keeping bedding dry and
clean a farmer who neglects these
elements will spend more on medicine and
Replacements but the wise farmer like
the stoic takes proactive steps to
prevent disasters before they
happen imagine two farmers John and
Mark John believes that chickens can
adapt to anything and builds a flimsy
cramped Coupe within months his chickens
develop diseases and he constantly
struggles with high mortality rates mark
on the other hand applies practical
wisdom he invests time in designing a
co-op with proper ventilation spacing
and hygiene his flock grows strong his
cost remain low and his productivity
increases while JN blames bad luck Mark
enjoys the rewards of his preparation
now here's your challenge inspect your
Coupe today ask yourself does it smell
bad is there enough airf flow is it too
crowded are the floors dry
if you find at least one issue commit to
fixing it this week a small Improvement
now will prevent bigger problems
later your success in chicken farming
begins with the actions you take
today let's move forward with wisdom and
preparation lesson two mastering
nutrition feeding for maximum growth and
health a a well-fed chicken is a
productive chicken nutrition is the key
to strong immune systems rapid growth
and high egg
production many farmers assume that
throwing any grain or leftovers to their
chickens is enough but the truth is a
well-planned diet separates successful
Farmers from struggling ones if your
chickens are not gaining weight or
producing enough eggs the problem is
likely in their diet
many farmers waste money on expensive
feeds without understanding what their
chickens truly need others cut costs by
using lowquality food leading to
malnutrition weak immune systems and
higher mortality rates feeding is not
just about filling their stomachs it's
about giving them the right balance of
protein vitamins and minerals to
optimize their health health and
productivity the right diet consists of
three key elements protein for muscle
development and egg production
energy-rich grains to maintain body
functions and vitamins and minerals to
strengthen
immunity ignoring any of these will
result in Weak and unproductive
chickens a farmer who understands
nutrition can reduce costs by using
local ingredients while maintaining High
efficiency meanwhile a farmer who
blindly follows commercial feed
recommendations without knowledge will
always struggle with unpredictable
results imagine two farmers Alex and Tom
Alex buys commercial feed without
question believing that more expensive
feed equals better results however he
constantly struggles with inconsistent
growth and high costs Tom on the other
hand studies poultry nutrition and
formulates his own feed using corn
soybeans fish meal and natural
supplements his chickens grow faster lay
more eggs and his expenses are
lower while Alex complains about high
feed prices Tom thrives because he
understands his flocks nutritional
needs now here's your challenge review
your feeding plan
today are you Rel rying solely on
Commercial feed are your chickens
getting enough protein are you wasting
money on unnecessary
supplements make one small change to
improve their diet this week the key to
success is knowledge not blind
spending take control of your nutrition
strategy and you'll see real results in
your flocks performance and
profitability lesson three
preventing
disease The Art of Keeping your flock
healthy a healthy flock is a profitable
flock disease prevention is not just
about reacting when chickens get sick
it's about creating a system that keeps
illness away in the first place many
farmers rely too much on
medication but the strongest Farmers
understand that true success comes from
prevention not treatment
if you've ever lost chickens to disease
you know how devastating it can
be many farmers wait until they see
symptoms before acting but by then the
damage is already done the best defense
is a good
offense strong
biocurity proper vaccination and strict
hygiene measures can mean the difference
between a thriving farm and one
struggling with constant losses
disease prevention rests on three key
pillars biocurity to prevent outside
infections from entering your
farm vaccination to protect against
common poultry diseases and hygiene to
keep living conditions clean and
stressfree a careless farmer who ignores
these principles will face constant
outbreaks high costs and
frustration but a disciplined farmer
like the stoic takes control by
establishing strict preventative
measures ensuring the health and
stability of their
flock consider two farmers David and
Eric David doesn't believe in prevention
he only treats sick chickens when
problems
arise his farm suffers from repeated
outbreaks and he spends more money on
medicine than he does on
feed Eric however takes a proactive
approach he enforces strict entry rules
vaccinates on schedule and keeps his
Coupe spotless his flock remains strong
his expenses stay low and his farm
thrives while David blames bad luck Eric
reaps the rewards of his careful
preparation here's your Challenge walk
through your farm today and assess your
biocurity measures our visitors freely
ENT ing your Coupe is your vaccination
schedule up to date our feed and water
sources
clean identify one weakness and fix it
this
week true success in chicken farming
comes not from reacting to problems but
from preventing them before they
happen take control now and your flock
and your profits will thank
you lesson four selecting the right
breed maximizing your Farm's potential
not all chickens are the same choosing
the right breed is one of the most
important decisions a farmer can make
whether you're raising chickens for meat
eggs or other purposes selecting the
right breed can mean the difference
between success and
failure many farmers make the mistake of
picking breeds based on Trends or
availability rather than their actual
farming
goals if your chickens are not growing
as expected laying fewer eggs or
struggling in your environment the
problem might not be your management it
could be the breed itself a breed that
thrives in one region May struggle in
another some breeds require more care
While others are Hardy and low
maintenance understanding this can save
you years of trial and error the key to
choosing the right breed lies in three
factors purpose whether for meat eggs or
Dual Purpose environment matching the
breed to your climate and farm
conditions and
maintenance understanding the level of
care and feeding
required a farmer who selects the wrong
breed will fight against nature dealing
with unnecessary costs and poor po
results but a wise farmer like the stoic
works with nature selecting the right
breed for the right conditions and
objectives imagine two farmers Chris and
Daniel Chris picks a breed because he
saw another farmer succeed with it but
he doesn't consider his different
climate and feeding
capacity his chickens grow slowly and
require constant medical attention
Daniel however studies different breeds
understands his Farm's limitations and
chooses one that is naturally suited to
his conditions his flock grows strong
his production stays high and his farm
prospers while Chris blames bad luck
Daniel enjoys the benefits of informed
decision making here's your challenge
evaluate your current breed or the one
you're planning to raise does it align
with your goals is it suited to your
Farm's climate and management style if
not consider making
adjustments the right breed can be the
key to unlocking your Farm's full
potential take control of this decision
and you'll set yourself up for long-term
success lesson five
financial management controlling costs
and maximizing profits a successful
chicken farm is not just about raising
healthy Birds it's about managing
finances wisely many farmers Focus only
on production but fail to track their
expenses leading to financial losses
even when their flocks are
thriving understanding how to control
costs and maximize profits is what
separates struggling Farmers from those
who succeed
longterm if you find yourself constantly
spending more than expected or
struggling to make a profit the issue is
not always market prices it's often poor
financial
planning many farmers spend too much on
unnecessary feed medicine or equipment
without properly calculating their
return on
investment a farm that ignores Financial
discipline will always be at risk no
matter how good the chickens
are effective financial management
depends on three principles budgeting
tracking every expense and setting clear
limits cost control minimizing waste and
unnecessary spending and profit
optimization finding ways to increase
Revenue without increasing
expenses a farmer who blindly spends
without planning will always struggle
while a disciplined farmer like the
stoic treats his farm like a business
making decisions based on numbers not
emotions consider two farmers Jake and
Paul Jake expands his farm without
tracking costs believing that more
chickens automatically mean more profit
soon he is overwhelmed by feed costs
medical bills and unexp Ed
losses Paul on the other hand carefully
calculates his expenses buys feed in
bulk at the right times and reinvests
only in proven
strategies while Jake struggles under
Financial pressure Paul builds a stable
and growing business one blames bad luck
the other succeeds through planning
here's your challenge sit down today and
review your Farm's finances
how much are you spending on feed
medicine and infrastructure are there
unnecessary expenses draining your
profits identify one area where you can
cut costs or optimize spending this
week smart financial decisions are what
keep Farms
sustainable master your numbers and
you'll master your Farm's
future lesson six mastering the market
selling chickens for maximum profit
raising chickens is only half the battle
the real challenge is selling them at
the right price and to the right
buyers many farmers work hard to raise
healthy chickens only to struggle with
poor sales low prices and unstable
markets understanding how to navigate
the market is what turns a poultry farm
from a hobby into a profitable business
business if you've ever sold chickens at
a loss or struggled to find buyers the
problem isn't just the market it's your
strategy many farmers rely on middlemen
sell at whatever price they are offered
or fail to build strong customer
relationships the key to success is not
just having a product but knowing how to
sell
it a successful sales strategy depends
on on three key factors
pricing understanding production costs
and setting profitable prices customer
relations building trust with Buyers to
ensure repeat sales and Market
positioning finding the best channels to
sell whether through direct sales bulk
contracts or Niche
markets a farmer who doesn't control
these elements is always at the mercy of
fluctuating prices
es while a strategic farmer like the
stoic takes control and finds ways to
maximize profit despite Market
challenges imagine two farmers Sam and
Peter Sam sells his chickens only when
he needs money accepting whatever price
the buyers
offer he struggles with inconsistent
income and Market
uncertainty Peter however studies the
market builds relationship sh with
restaurants and retailers and times his
sales
strategically he negotiates better
prices and secures long-term
contracts while Sam blames the market
Peter thrives because he understands how
to work with it here's your challenge
review your sales strategy today are you
tracking production costs to ensure
profitability are you relying too much
on middlemen have you explored new
markets or direct sales
opportunities identify one Improvement
and take action this week selling
chickens profitably is not about luck
it's about preparation and
strategy take control and your farm will
Thrive lesson
seven understanding chicken Behavior
reducing stress and maximizing
growth successful chicken Farmers don't
just feed their Birds they understand
them chickens have natural behaviors
that if properly managed can lead to
Better Health higher productivity and
reduced
losses however many farmers Overlook
these behaviors leading to unnecessary
stress pecking issues and poor growth
rates
if your chickens are frequently fighting
laying fewer eggs or seem overly
stressed the issue might not be their
diet or housing it could be how their
environment affects their
behavior stress weakens the immune
system slows growth and increases
aggression understanding chicken
psychology is just as important as
nutrition and
housing managing chicken Behavior
revolves around three key principles
space ensuring each bird has enough room
to move and establish its place in the
flock social
structure understanding pecking order
and minimizing aggression and
environmental
enrichment providing perches dust baths
and stimulation to keep chickens active
and
healthy farmers who ignore these
elements will constantly struggle with
stress related problems while those who
manage Behavior wisely like the stoic
create a balanced productive flock
consider two farmers Mike and
Sarah Mike overcrowd his chickens
ignoring their natural need for space
and Order his Birds frequently fight
suffer injuries and produce fewer eggs
Sarah however observes her flocks
behavior and adjusts accordingly she
provides enough space separates
aggressive birds and enriches their
environment her chickens are calmer
healthier and far more
productive while Mike blames bad luck
Sarah succeeds through careful
management here's your challenge spend
time observing your chickens today are
they fighting more than usual do they
have enough space are they showing signs
of stress such as feather pecking or low
activity identify one area to improve
and take action this week a calm
well-managed flock leads to Better
Health growth and
profitability take control of their
behavior and you'll take control of your
farm
success lesson eight enhancing
productivity strategies to improve
efficiency in chicken
farming raising chickens is not just
about survival it's about
optimization many farmers managed to
keep their chickens alive but fail to
maximize their Farm's efficiency small
improvements in daily operations can
lead to significant increases in
productivity and profit if your chickens
are growing slower than expected laying
fewer eggs or your farm requires too
much labor the issue might not be
external it might be
inefficiency many farmers waste time
money and resources because they don't
refine their farming methods a more
efficient Farm is a more profitable
Farm improving efficiency in chicken
farming depends on Three core
principles automation using technology
to save time and reduce labor cost
routine
optimization structuring feeding
cleaning and health checks for maximum
Effectiveness and Resource Management
minimizing waste and making the most of
available space and feed a farmer who
ignores these factors will always
struggle with wasted effort while a
strategic farmer like the stoic
constantly seeks ways to improve and
refine
operations take two Farmers Andrew and
James Andrew follows the same old
methods year after year manually feeding
his chickens and spending hours on
unnecessary tasks he is constantly
exhausted and his farm grows
slowly James however invests in simple
automation tools optimizes his daily
routine and eliminates wasteful
practices his farm runs smoothly with
less effort and higher returns
while Andrew feels trapped in hard labor
James enjoys the benefits of working
smarter not
harder here's your
challenge identify one inefficient area
in your farm
today are you spending too much time on
tasks that could be automated is your
feeding schedule optimized for maximum
growth are you wasting
resources choose one area to improve
improve and take action this
week continuous Improvement is the key
to long-term
success work smarter and your farm will
Thrive lesson nine overcoming challenges
building resilience in chicken
farming every farmer faces challenges
disease outbreaks fluctuating market
prices extreme weather and unexpected
loss es can turn a thriving Farm into a
struggle however successful farmers do
not fear adversity they prepare for it
and learn to
adapt the key to long-term success is
resilience if you've ever felt
overwhelmed by setbacks in your farm
know that you're not
alone many farmers give up too soon
because they expect things to always go
smoothly the truth is farming is UN
predictable and those who succeed are
the ones who build strategies to handle
problems before they
happen resilience in farming depends on
three essential principles risk
management having backup plans for feed
shortages disease outbreaks and price
drops
adaptability adjusting strategies based
on new challenges and market conditions
and long-term thinking investing in
sustainable practices rather than
chasing short-term
gains farmers who panic in tough times
often make rash decisions but those who
remain calm and strategic like the stoic
endure and Thrive consider two farmers
Kevin and Robert Kevin runs his farm
well when times are good but when feed
prices rise he panics sells his flock at
a loss and struggles to
recover Robert on on the other hand
prepares in advance he diversifies his
income builds emergency reserves and
constantly
adapts while Kevin blames bad luck
Robert grows stronger with every
challenge here's your challenge identify
one potential risk to your farm today is
it disease Market fluctuations Feed
Supply create a simple plan to address
this risk before it becomes a crisis
strong farmers are not those who never
face problems but those who know how to
overcome them build resilience and your
farm will stand the test of
time you now have the essential keys to
successful poultry farming from building
a solid Coupe to mastering nutrition
disease prevention and Market strategies
each lesson is a stepping stone toward a
thriving
Farm challenge es will come but remember
true success comes from preparation and
adaptation as the stoics teach control
what you can and accept what you cannot
apply these lessons take action and
continuously
improve your farm success is in your
hands stay disciplined stay prepared and
let your farm flourish